a unit vector is just a vector that has
a unit or a length of one so unit just
means that it's one unit or one one unit
long but what we want is we want the
vector to go in the same direction as
this vector here 3/4 so how do we find a
unit vector that's going in the same
direction as this vector but it's only
one unit in length well here's what
we're going to do we're going to take
the vector ok represented by V divided
by the magnitude okay which is the
length of this vector V so here we have
3/4 divided by the magnitude of this
vector which you can see is x squared
plus y squared to take the square root
just doing Pythagorean theorem that
gives us the length of the vector which
is 5 and if you divide both the x and
the y component of the vector by by the
magnitude you're going to get the unit
vector which is 3 5 comma 4 5 and that's
our unit vector so it just means you're
going 3/5 of a unit to the right 4/5 of
a unit up and you can see you're going
to have a vector like this ok that's
going in the same direction as that
factor but it's only one unit in length
so again all you have to do is take the
vector divided by the length of the
vector the magnitude and that will give
you the unit vector now if you want to
prove it to yourself that this is just
one unit what you can do is you take the
this vector here 3/5 squared plus 4/5
squared take the square root you get
nine twenty fifths plus 16 2015 5 2015 2
and you've got it I'll see you in the
next video